eu eu venho do outro lado de cá do canal
é de de são sebastião eu sou de ilhabela
e nós temos uma experiência social que
se chama espaço cultural pé no chão é é
o pé no chão é uma entidade não é uma
ong e eu tenho a honra de fazer parte
dela e lá é um lugar onde nós fazemos
experiências sociais a partir de um
contexto de práticas artísticas
é um lugar de inventar histórias e
colocá-las no palco e nós fazemos toda
essa experiência social através de uma
ferramenta que todos conhecem que se
chama arte educação é com ela que nós
planejamos todo esse movimento que nós
que nós fazemos lá
já faz 15 anos que nós celebramos a vida
assim brincando de faz de conta é
colocando arte na vida das crianças e
das pessoas e como todos sabem arte é
uma ferramenta muito importante na
formação da criança porque ela colabora
com o desenvolvimento expressivo com o
desenvolvimento da sua criatividade e
isso vai fazer com que a criança se
torne é um ser humano um adulto né mais
sensível e aí ele vai poder realmente
olhar o mundo com outros olhos a agir no
mundo né de uma outra de uma outra
maneira isso realmente pode fazer a
diferença é fazer uma criança e o palco
tem um impacto transformador na sua na
sua maturidade porque essa brincadeira
ela ela precisa de uma atitude externa
de um atitude interna de exposição é
muito grande porque pra ir pro palco
contar uma história você precisa
realmente se
porém se expressar bastante até mesmo
você sendo um abajur
você tem que que se expressar ao menos
como um abajur e o que é legal que é o
seu a junho é que você que você vai
pensar né ea partir daí se essa criança
permanece na na atividade ela vai sim
poder andando mas sim poder andando e se
aproxima de certas certezas ou então ela
transforma insegurança e incertezas e
claro é muito mais fácil ir adiante
quando a gente está cheio de certeza é
bem mais interessante e e fica muito
mais bonito nem quando a gente está indo
com certeza e nós podemos perceber lá no
caso do chão como as crianças ficam
realmente mais lindas quando elas estão
entregues ea esses protagonismos né
é super fácil de perceber isso né
e é muito visível também pois a praticar
essas experiências que possibilitam elas
dominar algumas técnicas e manejar
certos elementos para expressar seus
papéis
a criança se fortalece com isso e aí
cria habilidades e competências que que
ajuda a construir essa auto-estima e
depois de um tempo essas pequenos eles
vão se transformando em pequenos super
heróis até mesmo todos os protagonistas
né das histórias que são contadas é
todos eles são heróis é até o o vilão um
é um grande herói é o anti herói é um
herói e então assim lá no pé no chão nós
temos é essa situação que é a ferramenta
da arte-educação e universo propícios
para atrair esses pequenos depois num
ambiente lúdico é é como se fosse uma
flor mesmo por uma abelha é é uma fração
imediata que acontece quando a criança
começa a se divertir com essas
experiências né
e depois depois de um tempo ela aprendi
essa aprendizagem ela vai criando
compreensões mais amplas né e e isso
ajuda
a criar de repente os seus princípios e
conceitos que depois disso alcança na
verdade uma posição construtiva mente
crítica das coisas do mundo né
isso é importante para esse meio teórico
mas na verdade é isso que nós fazemos no
pés no chão nós somos produtores de uma
cultura lúdica é um mundo de faz de
conta e na verdade esse é o segredo da
nossa tecnologia social vamos dizer
assim é o estabelecimento a criação
estabelecimento desse espaço lúdico é
que é o pé no chão é esquecido e mudar e
na verdade sempre a gente reflete sobre
a magia que foi conseguir comprar esse
terreno e construir essa nossa essa
nossa sede é tem muita coisa por fazer
ainda mas nós temos duas salas de aulas
bem interessante temos um rol de entrada
temos um né um jardim e principalmente
nós temos um palco
nós temos um palco interessante no selo
já se apresentou lá nós temos um pouco
interessante um camarim e uma
arquibancada para mais de 170 pessoas
entrarem nesse mundo lúdico da fantasia
e um dos fatores mais importantes da
atividade lúdica é o fato dela ser
geradora de prazer
é por isso que a coisa pega né e e essas
sensações geradas elas prevalecem no ao
longo do tempo e esse essa vivência que
a criança tem é forte ela será lembrada
né ea história inclusive será marcada na
lembrança e na memória dessas dessas
crianças né
e assim na verdade isso teoricamente
seria informa informação cultural
vivencial
mas só pra gente isso assim a criança tá
pegando na proposta ora que acontece
isso porque como é que ela vai poder
esquecer né
se ela de repente ela foi o pirata
thomas cavendish é que que se escondia
na bahia que seremos e saqueava a vila
de santos como ela vai esquecer que ela
foi escrava josefa que que fugiu de uma
fazenda
de paraty para se abrigar nas matas de
ubatuba ou então é o visconde partido ao
meio metade boa e metade metade ruim né
ou então um ou então é o cavaleiro
inexistente de ítalo calvino e outros
personagens que nem são tão marcantes
como um lobisomem uma mãe uma tia uma
irmã e uma prima é um vizinho um
motorista quer dizer não para mais de
possibilidades né ea imaginação ela não
pode parar mesmo porque nós temos que
salvar a espécie não é mesmo e assim se
é para salvar a espécie aí que a
imaginação nos deixa na mão porque em
miguel o filho do vento que protege
contra o esgoto que é jogado na cidade
ou então um velho mestre raizeiro que
prepara as suas poções e coloca no
reservatório de água da cidade dá todas
as pessoas beberem dessa água e criar em
consciência
ou então podemos ser joão de ferro
ensinar ética de uma maneira simples e
firme na formação de um filho de um rei
ou então criar um culto scott no jardim
para discutir ciência vai tentar impedir
uma epidemia que assola a cidade
então é muita coisa realmente que a
gente pode é vivenciar nem com todo esse
processo da arte educação
mas a coisa não é só aí não ela na
verdade ela ela vai mais além porque
olha que a criança vem vem a mãe nem o
pai vem o padrasto vem a madrasta vêm os
avós e é aí que acontece é esse
sentimento desse laboratório de
experiências sociais ele se amplia
porque a gente tem a família toda ali e
muitas vezes as famílias elas não sabem
do potencial expressivo e criativa dos
seus filhos e de repente ela vai lá e o
seu filho está sendo um desses
personagens que eu falei agora pouco e
com isso é assim encanta a todos e faz a
alegria de todos é é bem interessante
tudo isso eu vou contar uma história
rapidinho é teve uma criança uma vez uma
situação durante espetáculo e essa
criança ela estava na coxia né
que é isso aqui estava prestes a entrar
em cena
essa rolando ea criança é soluçava de
tanto chorar quando eu percebi eu me
aproximei dela estava na contra a regra
e que está acontecendo e aí ele falou
assim eu não sei se vou conseguir entrar
em cena e falar dizendo as minhas falas
né
aí eu chorando ea peça acontecendo e aí
eu peguei e meninas em uma super no
rosto dele e falei pra ele assim é na
verdade você consegue porque você
participou de todos os ensaios você fez
tudo certinho né
aí o menino entrou foi lá foi entrou e
fez e no final
aí ele vem correndo abraçar dizendo que
tinha conseguido né
é claro ele conseguiu mesmo não quer
dizer isso é uma coisa de força e de
prova realmente na vida de uma criança e
é muito interessante de de vivenciar
tudo isso né e e assim nesses 15 anos né
de pés no chão foram mais ou menos uns
quatro mil alunos que passaram pela
nossa história é vestindo figurino sendo
o palco dançando entretanto os papéis ou
pintando com pincéis jogando capoeira é
é foram muitas possibilidades de
realmente de crescimento entrega né
e também nós fizemos bastante assim de
inocular magia e fantasia em quase 40
mil pessoas que presenciaram nossos
espetáculos e as nossas as nossas ações
culturais né
e então assim é o que eu queria terminar
falando é que assim a gente fortalecer
mesmo uma greve agora é de proteção e
fortalecimento das entidades dos
coletivos como esse da galera do ted
como é é grupos e pessoas mesmo as que
estão por aí humildemente zelando pela
alegria do mundo
obrigado